the sequel to final fantasy vii remake
has been revealed and it even has a
release window
yesterday square enix held a live stream
for the 25th anniversary of final
fantasy vii during the stream square
announced the return of crisis core
final fantasy vii which will be ported
slash remastered and launches on all
consoles and pc this winter which could
mean end of this year or beginning of
next year i feel like a lot of people
forget that winter crosses over so don't
get too hyped for a 2022 release date
crisis core final fantasy vii is an
action rpg and prequel to the original
final fantasy vii release the game
follows zak fair the bff to cloud strife
during his time as a mercenary for the
shinra electric power company this
remaster marks the first time in 14
years that crisis core will be playable
on modern platforms as there have been
no other ports of the game since its
original launch on the psp in march of
2008 crisis core final fantasy vii
remastered will launch this winter on
xbox one xbox series xns playstation 4
and 5 nintendo switch and pc so if the
final fantasy 7 prequel is coming to
xbox then that should mean the remake is
coming to xbox well not exactly
unfortunately there was still no mention
of the game making an appearance on
microsoft's consoles instead square
announced that pc players would now be
able to buy final fantasy 7 remake
integrate via steam starting on june
17th and if you're lucky enough to have
a steam deck you'll be happy to know
that integrate is verified but if you're
like me and you've already beaten remake
then you might be more interested in
part 2 instead of just another store to
buy part 1 from luckily the sequel did
make an appearance and it's called final
fantasy 7 rebirth instead of remake part
2. square also noted that this is the
second entry in a trilogy marking our
first official understanding of how many
parts this new final fantasy 7 series
will be the trailer explored the
cliffhanger left by the first game with
various characters exploring what it
means now that fate has seemingly been
changed final fantasy 7 rebirth is
coming next winter on playstation 5 and
i'm starting to feel so invested that i
might actually play the original now but
if i don't end up playing it soon it
might be because nintendo has confirmed
that pokemon snap will be added to
switch online and expansion pack on june
24th originally released on the n64 in
1999 pokemon snap was a departure from
the usual rpgs in the series as players
were tasked with capturing pokemon on
film and not in pokeballs last year new
pokemon snap debuted and fleshed out the
safari experience with a more vivid and
captivating selection of pokemon on
switch so now you can easily switch
between the two versions in a snap
let me know in the comments how corny my
jokes are let me know what you're
playing this weekend and i'll see you
next week
you